coronavirus is a global pandemic it
affects all of us and every country in
the world more than two and a half
million people have been infected so far
and we have lost almost 180,000 people
to this virus and it is still spreading
fast the response to this pandemic can
only be global we need cooperation
between governments across the world
scientists civil society business
citizens and this is why we are
organizing a global online pledging
conference on the 4th of May the aim is
to join forces and mobilize resources we
need to develop as soon as possible a
vaccine produce it and deploy to every
single corner of the world and we need
to ramp up work on prevention
diagnostics and treatments and for this
we need money so one of the main
objectives of the summit will be to
raise an initial sum of 7.5 billion euro
to kick-start the global cooperation
more will be needed in future and we
want to bring together the world and its
leaders to jointly defeat the virus I am
grateful to the experienced
organizations which are working with us
on this the global preparedness
monitoring board the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation the Wellcome Trust the
World Health Organization and many many
others they bring valuable expertise in
this area and I'm encouraged by the many
signs of engagement from people all over
the world
singers artists citizens sports people
business leaders we are inspired by them
and we hope that we can mobilize a
strong international response together
we are stronger and we will defeat this
virus